best friends is a 33 thousand acre
refuge in Utah with a simple philosophy
kindness to animals makes a better world
for us all dog tail is the canine
facility here we trainer John Garcia
assists a young dog from a North
Carolina shelter who arrived with a
mangled leg their little brother Wiley
was run over twice by a car and left for
dead
now the dog's front leg may need to be
amputated his foot was in really bad
shape he whether he was in pain or
frustrated decided to chew off some of
his toes on that injured foot and then
developed a severe infection 44:6
all right come on but the outcome of
poor little Wiley wouldn't have been
good if he didn't come to best friends
most people consider that definitely
unadoptable and a low quality life
enough to euthanize boy it's all right
buddy
dr. Mike tries to comfort the
one-year-old dog as he assesses the
damage go boy can you bend your elbow
boy I know I know at this point the
damage is already done we didn't find
any brakes on exercise that we could fix
and if we did with the muscles being
contracted there's no anything he could
do to return that leg to function the
leg must be immediately amputated the
younger is the early it gets adjusted to
be free like a dog the better off it's
gonna be because you can see kind of
puts it down he kind of plants on this
so he does put weight on it we don't
want him to get too used to doing that
but he seems to be a very very nice boy
thank you dr. Mike must perform a long
and difficult surgery and while he
survival depends on his success
telling your alphabet up you want to
leave a fair amount of fat that's gonna
stay with the dog go out here be a
little R for some the suturing before
removing the leg dr. Mike must locate
and secure the muscles we'll need to
close the dog's chest once the leg is
gone all right
so now I think we're gonna start cutting
some of these muscles after careful
labor the big moment has arrived yeah
we're about ready to take the leg off
but could actually go underneath but
kind of go at this angle so we get a
fair amount of muscle left okay
the leg is off but there's still work to
be done right here's a muscle here's a
muscle you want to get those two
together
Wiley's injured chest muscles are
deformed and weak
the surgeons struggle to close the wound
now I have to suture the non-existent
muscles together so close up that gap
tie that they're perfect finally they're
able to close Wiley's wound and the
surgery is complete ice work
the dogs muscles may take weeks to fully
heal well check them out tomorrow see
how he's doing
soon Wiley will face a huge challenge
learning to walk with only one front leg
the biggest thing for him is going to be
adjusting had only three legs and not
having that balance aspect it's been
only 24 hours since the dogs leg was
amputated but dr. Mike wants Wiley to
take at least a couple of steps today he
didn't really want to go he was very
hesitant and scared it's important to
get him walking just so he gets you
still having three legs it's not like
physical therapy and people need to make
him do it and make him do it soon let's
see how he does it's kind of leaning on
him a lot he's kind of falling to his
left pretty bad with him with the front
leg he didn't really use it but he would
support himself on it and so it was
different for him to not have that
ability
Laska there we go there we go let's get
you outside buddy here we go come on
don't fall there we go I got you this
side I'll support you while he was
leaning really hard against me and
trying just using his one leg in me as
his support you ready to go buddy
because dogs carry more weight in the
front half of their bodies it's harder
for them to lose the front leg do it
today will be a success if Wiley takes
it even a few steps by himself boy get
yourself bounced moving a front limb is
a little bit tougher because up front
that's where most of the weight is you
know I'm very excited about seeing these
animals that we know and love get better
boy you love them up a little bit you
hug them you a dime on the head and we
want to make them get better yes